[Musique]
bonsoir je m'appelle juliette et je suis
prof fille de prof petite fille de prof
et les 10 les charges et non avant de
commencer mon taux que je vous raconte
ma rencontre avec amy amy c'est elle qui
va me faire réaliser que je suis pas du
tout formés pour être prof au collège
dans une zone sensible
c'est un peu bête parce que c'est là que
je me retrouve la première année et mis
quand j'arrive dans mon collège de
banlieue parisienne
c'est une élève de 6e et en début
d'année il ya un autre élève de 6e qui a
sous-entendu que c'était une heure
péripatéticienne vous regardez sur un
pareil et amy elle n'a pas du tout
apprécié elle a attendu à la fin de mon
cours et elle lui a collé une droite
comme ça dans l'est et là je me suis dit
qu'on avait un petit problème de
formation
est ce que vous savez comment on devient
prof en 2013 quand je le besoin
peut-être que vous vous dites être
propre c'est un petit peu comme être
médecin
ça demande énormément de connaissances
dans son domaine et puis appliquez les
bons gestes au bon moment ça voudrait
dire pour moi qui suis prof de français
avoir passé de longues études a étudié
la littérature et puis la pédagogie
évidemment et puis faire un bon nombre
de stages
ce serait logique mais c'est pas du tout
comme ça que ça se passe en réalité
pendant mes cinq années d'études pour
devenir enseignante
je n'ai jamais vu un élève et je n'ai
jamais entendu parler de pédagogie tout
ce que j'ai fait pendant mes cinq études
pour devenir prof
ce sont des dissertations j'ai été
recruté pour ma capacité à disserter de
la citation suivante parce qu'elle
embrasse passionnément le présent la
poésie affronte une un signifiance le
sens du présent et danse est un
signifiant ce dans ce cadrage impossible
des perspectives dans ce flottement des
savoirs dans cette fuite des
significations face à nos discours et
nos croyances
vous avez six heures alors bon moi j'ai
rien d'autre christian prigent à
l'auteur de cette citation mais déjà
pendant mes études je voyais pas bien
rapport entre ce que je faisais et mon
quotidien prof est clairement quand amy
s'est battu à la fin de boncourt
j'ai vraiment pas vu l'intérêt d'avoir
fait pendant toutes ces années des plans
thèse antithèse synthèse grâce à emi
j'ai compris que mon cours sur l'accord
du cod hanté poser avec le participe
passé et l'auxiliaire avoir ça n'allait
pas enthousiasmé les foules et
d'ailleurs ça n'avait pas enthousiasmé
emi qui elle pas c'est montcourt et sa
journée une manière générale à réfléchir
à son petit problème de réputation
le problème c'est que tant que je
n'avais pas intéressé et emi ce jeu ne
servait à rien puisque en fait et amy
elle était comme tous mes élèves
elle avait la tête pleine de problèmes
plein d'histoires à gérer plein de
petits frères à aller chercher deux
corvées ménagères à faire la maison ans
en bref plein de choses qui l'empêché
d'être vraiment pleinement cours
quand moi j'avais besoin d'elle
grâce à aimer j'ai mis mon cours sur le
cod ont été posées de côté pour un temps
et je me suis intéressé à faire entrer
mes élèves dans mes dons mais dans ma
classe et là vous allez me dire dans mes
lunettes même en sixième quand même un
programme genre molière tout ça et oui
pas mal même en sixième d'un programme
et vous avez raison on fait toujours
molière mais dans mon collège on a 60 %
de réussite au mauvais
60 %
donc je me suis dit que bon avec ces
résultats la cie déjà j'arrivais à
donner à mes élèves
l' envie de venir au collège bart
j'aurais pas totalement failli à ma
mission
donc à la suite de cette bagarre en
classe je tâtonne
et ma salle devient un peu un grand
chantier expérimental
je la change totalement j'installe dans
le fond une grande ville enfin une
bibliothèque avec un fauteuil
confortable où les élèves peuvent venir
il ya même des tapis de yoga qui faisait
plier les murs sont colorés comme vous
le voyez et je fais entrer des
innovations pédagogiques alors on a tous
entendu parler montessori je m'en
inspire on fait même de l'art web radio
c'est un peu un joyeux bazar
avec des très bons moments et des grands
moments de solitude
je vous en raconter un on travaille sur
les prix nobel de la paix parce que je
veux montrer à mes élèves que on peut
lutter à sans violence et être célèbre
pour son courage sans violence et je
m'approche d'un des groupes pour leur
demander où ils en sont et là il me
regarde fièrement au mieux disant
barrière madame nous on travaille sur
martin luther king et on a choisi de
l'incrusté dans un groupe
dans un clip de rap il va jeter des
dollars à la foule en chantant of dreams
alors moi je me suis effondré d'un tout
simplement et je pense que martin luther
king s'est retrouvé dans sa peau se
retourner dans sa tombe
donc là on est en 2016 je travaille h 24
pour essayer de rendre mes cours
intéressants et et motivant pour mes
élèves
et pourtant je me dis que je vais pas
assez loin que je dois aller voir
ailleurs et là commence à germer l'idée
d'un tour du monde de l'éducation
je me dis c'est bien simple j'ai des
convictions très fortes sur l'éducation
j'ai même des certitudes
je vais aller voir des gens qui pensent
exactement comme moi voir comment ils
font pour faire exactement comme moi
mais en mieux quand même ramené leurs
idées
chez moi dans mon collège tous mes
élèves seront en réussite motivé heureux
épanoui moi je serai sacré où il reprend
du monde évidemment
et aulas bon vous savez ça c'était
l'idée 1 s'est pas passé comme ça au
départ tout se passe bien je visite
pendant les premiers mois dans les pays
asiatiques des écoles innovantes qui
mettent leurs élèves au centre de leur
pédagogie qui les rendent acteurs du
monde dans lequel ils vivent je discute
avec des élèves qui sont matures qui me
parlent d'égal à égal qui me parle
d'écologie de justice sociale de
citoyenneté je suis en plein kif
au bout de quelques mois je descends de
mon nuage je réalise quand même que
depuis le début
j'ai été que dans des établissements
assez favoriser voire très favoris sauf
que c'est pas du tout ma réalité - ma
réalité à une trentaine de kilomètres de
paris
quant à elle été fondé dans les années
70 on l'a appelée la cité des enfants
c'était censé être une bouffée d'air pur
pour les parisiens le week-end sauf que
maintenant les seuls parisiens qui
viennent sont les preuves comme moi en
début de carrière et les journalistes en
quête de sensationnalisme donc très loin
de ces établissements que j'ai visitée
depuis le début
donc là je réalise que toutes ces
innovations que j'ai vu on va pouvoir
intégrer directement l'école publique en
revanche l'école publique et c'est
vraiment ce en quoi je crois
fondamentalement doit donner la chance à
tout le monde de réussir et d'avoir le
choix
cette idée fait son petit tour dans ma
tête et je continue mon chemin
quelques mois plus tard j'arrive à new
york
et je range me rends dans un
établissement très similaires ou très
similaire sauf que dans cet
établissement là les élèves parviennent
au bac
et arrive à l'université
là vous allez me dire brésil est de nous
la recette on applique ont fait la même
chose en france et moi-même je me disais
je vais trouver des choses incroyables
que je n'ai jamais vu donc je n'ai
jamais entendu parler ça va être fou
bon en fait pas du tout ce que j'ai vu
c'est des cours extrêmement structurée
des profs qui sont derrière chaque élève
qui arrive à créer un climat de
confiance mais qui pourtant mais
toujours le savoir au coeur du court
pour moi c'est un choc
déception légèrement et en même temps à
ce moment là j'ai atterri et je me dis
que bah oui en fait tant que mes élèves
ne seront pas exprimer des idées
complexes
même si moi mon rêve c'est de parler
d'écologie d'engagement de justice
sociale bah on pourra jamais pensé ces
sujets là
donc vous voyez cette école à new york
me fait réfléchir elle m'inspire sur
certains points et en même temps sur
d'autres
ça me chiffonne parce qu'en fait dans
cette dans cette école là comme vous le
voyez tout le monde est bien sage c'est
assez militaire d'idron
il ya beaucoup de sanctions beaucoup
d'heures de retenue d exclusion et de
manière générale ce côté dépressif me
plaît à mentir
on l'est toujours pas trouvé mon système
éducatif parfait je continue mon voyage
et quelques mois plus tard je vous
retrouve enfin le monde
bon on en a entendu parler de la
finlande
il ya beaucoup de clichés beaucoup de
fantasmes sur la finlande mais c'est
vrai que moi ce que j'ai vu c'est cet
équilibre entre l'exigence que j'ai vu à
new york et la confiance que j'avais vu
dans ces pays asiatiques et dans les
écoles innovantes en asie
juste pour vous faire un petit peu rêver
en finlande il n'est jamais question de
sanctions
pas d'heure de revenus pas de conseils
de discipline évidemment pas d'exclusion
les profs on les appelle par leur prénom
on les tutoie on déjeune même avait que
halak entier ça c'est pour le côté
confiance pour le côté exigence que j'ai
vu c'est que dans chaque heure de cours
on s'attache et a réellement donné à
nourrir les élèves à leur donner quelque
chose à apprendre
ils étaient les cours étaient structurés
et d'ailleurs dans les évaluations
internationales qui jugent le niveau des
élèves dans différents systèmes
éducatifs depuis les années 2000
la finlande est au top
je rentre dans mon tour du monde j'ai
parcouru 18 pays pendant dix mois j'ai
vu plus de 50 établissements qu'est ce
que je retiens
la première chose que je retiens c'est
que déjà contrairement à ce que je
croyais y a pas de formule magique ya
pas de recette miracle pour l'éducation
ensuite ce sont pas les technologies ni
les innovations pédagogiques qui vont
sauver l'école
en revanche l'éducation se doivent de
trouver un équilibre entre l'exigence et
la confiance est là je vous entends déjà
me dire ce que je vous fais beaucoup
parlé ce soir que l'exigence vous savez
déjà ce que c'est les emplois du temps
surchargés les notes ras des pâquerettes
et les commentaires des profs qui sont
désobligeant pour vous tirer vers le
haut
alors je vous arrête tout de suite ça
c'est pas vraiment ce que j'appelle de
l'exigence moi ce que je mets derrière
ce terme exigences et de dire que auch à
au sein de chaque heure de cours il faut
qu'on puisse toucher la beauté et la
complexité du savoir
ce que vous le savez on entre dans le
21e siècle et on le dit assez pour ne
pas les oublier
ce 21ème siècle est très instable
personne ne sait quels sont les métiers
de demain on ne sait plus
tout facile et pourtant la réponse que
je vais vous donner elle va être
paradoxal c'est que justement
il faut un socle précis de connaissances
et de savoir pour pouvoir se repérer
dans ce monde entier sans cesse en
mutation
quand finalement tout bascule qu'on sait
plus qui a raison qui a tort
eh ben c'est justement le fait d'avoir
des repères précis et stable dans le
monde qui va nous permettre d'avancer et
de réfléchir
c'est ça uniquement qui va nous
permettre de sortir des clichés de
sortir de la violence et de trouver de
nouvelles voies
alors je sais que c'est pas du tout sexy
de vous dire ça mais les élèves que je
côtoie chaque jour
angers voix quand je vois mes élèves
qu'on surnomme tous un peu mes élèves de
6e qui lisent comme des ce1 mes élèves
de troisième qui quand je leur posais
une question mme exil à damas tête mais
je ne sais pas comment l'exprimer
parce qu'ils n'ont pas assez de
vocabulaire je peux pas vous dire que la
solution c'est juste l'amour la
confiance et la bienveillance est trop
facile je ne peux pas vous le dire ce
soir la première des réponses est la
plus fondamentale c'est avant tout
l'exigeant santé en revanche ce que je
crois profondément est ce que mon tour
du monde m'a permis de prouver c'est que
cette exigence intellectuelle
elle ne peut aller de pair qu'avec la
chance que maintenant vous êtes né
nouvelle génération il faut que l'école
vous donne une vraie responsabilité au
quotidien il faut pour vous donne votre
voix il faut que nous les enseignants on
vous engage
on vous invite et on vous encourage
vivement à vous engager dans le monde a
changé la société dans laquelle vous
vivez
donc moi maintenant je reprends mon
chemin et mes cours sont beaucoup plus
classique qu'avant c'est vrai mais face
à chacun de mes élèves comme face à vous
ce soir je voi adultes en devenir et
j'essaye de lui donner tous les outils
pour qu'ils puissent réussir
et vous savez je suis juste une prof
ordinaire parce que nous sommes nombreux
à croire en vous donc faisons de
confiance et laissons-nous nous
surprendre merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]